Watch carefully.
[SIGH]
Look at that.
Oh, boy.
F****** delicious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Oh, my Lord.
I decided to teach a
second MasterClass.
Oh, boy.
This time around, I'm going
to take you into an area
where you felt your home
cooking could never go.
The secret behind any great
soufflé is in the buttering
of the mold.
You brush vertical strokes up.
This crispy chicken
salad, for me,
is the get out of jail
card, especially when you've
got a big dinner party, because
that is good enough for four
or five of you.
Grab a leaf, lift it up.
Now, I'm fed up when you
see chefs boiling asparagus.
Beautiful.
You get a free facial
at the same time.
Cooking is a labor of love.
Stay close to every
step of the way.
I'm going to teach you methods--
secrets-- that I'm teaching some
of the best chefs in the world
today.
I'm Gordon Ramsay, and
this is my MasterClass.